saha
chaque soir est un moment de communion
sportive
au chant et une danse sont dédiés à
chacun des joueurs pendant le jeu
malgré les apparences les spectateurs
sont attentifs au déroulement de la
partie
quand l'équipe marque c'est l'heure de
la danse des points
quand c'est votre première expérience du
baseball taiwanais en personne c'est une
ambiance grise en ce
moment magique pour la petite chine qui
partageait déjà la passion de son papa
est dit venus étudier et vivre à tainan
dans les années 90 pour pouvoir suivre
son équipe de
la ligue cbbl en est à sa 33e saison
elle se relève d importants scandales de
paris sportifs en 96 et en 2008 le
gouvernement taïwanais a même dû
intervenir pour nettoyer le sport
confiance retrouvée les partisans des
équipes adverses suivaient nouveau leurs
préférés sur les routes
[Musique]
le baseball fait partie de l'identité
taïwanaise
nationale une grande fierté
on dirait qu'en amérique les gens
veulent plutôt prendre une bière et
manger pendant la partie et votre
musique
malgré la chaleur intense l'ambiance
carnavalesque règne dans les stades de
taïwan comme partout en asie ça peut
être déroutant pour les canadiens et les
autres joueurs étrangers a
besoin
c'est très chaud et humide les
partitions chanter ils ont cassé pendant
près de quatre heures ils doivent
maintenant trouver de l'énergie pour
recommencer demain et le surlendemain le
résultat importe peu seul le plaisir du
club la radio
d'état